-Today was Joe Biden's
first full day as president,
and as and set to work
cleaning up the mess
left by his predecessor,
Republicans predictably
lost their minds.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
It is very hard to overstate
the sheer magnitude
of the crisis left behind
by the Trump administration.
It's unprecedented
in our lifetimes
and in modern
American history.
And in the short term,
it's only getting worse.
For one thing, Biden inherited
the worst economy
since the Great Depression.
And as we learned this morning,
900,000 Americans filed
for jobless claims
last week,
which means this is now
the second time in 12 years
Biden has been part of
an administration
that inherited an economy
in smoldering ruins
from a Republican
predecessor.
Biden's like the grandpa who
sits quietly in the recliner
all day,
reading a newspaper,
but then,
when it gets too cold,
you have to ask him
to chop the firewood
because no one else
knows how.
"Get out of the way, kid,
you're gonna hurt yourself
with that ax.
Now, why don't you
and your can noodle arms
go play some more
Minecraft."
So, Biden started by signing a
total of 17 executive actions
on his first day in office
yesterday.
And then, today, he discussed
his administration's
COVID response,
and signed 10 more.
-Joe Biden already signing
17 executive orders,
some of them focusing on
the coronavirus.
10 more today, focusing
specifically on the pandemic.
-Moments ago,
the president also speaking,
signing those
executive actions
aimed at changing the course
of the pandemic in this country,
including
expanding testing,
accelerating vaccinations,
and safely reopening schools.
-As we indicated earlier,
we're gonna be signing
a number of executive orders
over the next several days
to a week,
And I'm gonna start today,
as the compounding crisis
of COVID-19,
along with the economic crisis
following that,
the climate crisis,
racial equity issues.
-So, you know, everything.
Like coming home thinking you
had a table delivered,
but it's just the pieces
for a table in a box.
"Crap. Okay."
Allen wrench time, Joe.
And that was just
the first round,
to undue heinous Trump policies
like the Muslim ban
and the Keystone Pipeline,
and stop construction
of the border wall,
among other things.
Biden also reentered
the U.S.
into the Paris
Climate Agreement,
which basically
sets goals
for limiting greenhouse
gas emissions.
It's the bare minimum we can do
to address climate change,
since large parts of the country
were, you know,
on fire for most
of the summer.
And yet, Texas Senator Ted Cruz
cannot help but weigh in
with a stunningly
stupid retort.
-The Texas Senator tweeted,
quote,
"By rejoining the Paris
Climate Agreement,
President Biden indicates he's
more interested in the views
of the citizens of Paris
than in the jobs
of the citizens of Pittsburgh."
-Well, I guess, with Trump gone,
there was an opening
for a new wildly objectionable
kazoo-voiced [bleep] heel.
Look, I know he just recycled
this line from Trump,
but it was dumb them,
and it's even dumber now.
For one thing, the Paris Climate
Accord isn't about Paris.
It was signed in Paris.
Are you really
this stupid?
Is your beard growing
into your brain?
Does Ted Cruz also think
New York Fashion Week
is about
New York fashion?
"And coming down
the runway now,
it's a delivery guy wearing
headphones on an electronic bike
who will not stop
for red lights."
Now, I should clarify,
Ted Cruz isn't that stupid.
He's a scheming, festering,
gym sock full of mayonnaise
who knows full well
that the city of Pittsburgh
voluntarily followed
the Paris Agreement
even after
Trump withdrew.
And personally, I think Ted Cruz
is the last person
who should pretend
to stick up for Pittsburgh,
since he just tried
to throw out the votes
of everyone who lives
in Pittsburgh.
Have you no shame, you
microwaved Aquaman Funko Pop?
And look, is my dad's from
there, so I'm biased,
but I hate that the core of this
is that Paris is fancy
and Pittsburgh
is blue collar,
when anyone who's been
to both places
knows the 'burgh
is just as pretty --
if not prettier --
than Paris.
We've got more bridges
than Venice,
three rivers
to Paris' one,
and last I checked,
you ain't gonna fine no incline
in the City of Lights.
So, Ted Cruz,
to use the local parlance
of my father's ancestral land,
you're a jagoff.
President Biden also reversed
Trump's decision
to leave the World
Health Organization
in the middle of
a deadly pandemic.
And today, Biden's new chief
medical adviser,
Dr. Anthony Fauci,
announced that the U.S.
would remain in the WHO.
And later in the day, he spoke
to the press at the White House.
-I am honored to announce
that the United States
will remain a member of
the World Health Organization.
Yesterday, President Biden
signed the letters
retracting the previous
administration's announcement
to withdraw from
the organization.
The idea that you can
get up here,
and talk about what you know,
what the evidence is,
what the science is,
and know that's it.
Let the science speak.
It is somewhat of
a liberating feeling.
-Basically vanished for a --
for a few months,
there, for a while.
Do you feel like
you're back now?
-I think so.
-Yesterday must have been
amazing for Fauci.
I picture him
waltzing down the block
of his old Brooklyn
neighborhood,
heads popping out of windows
like a Neil Simon play.
"Hey, it's Fauci.
Yo, Facui!"
"That's right, baby,
I'm back!
I'll meet you down
in Mickey's!
Next round of vaccines
are on Tony the Fauc!"
Fauci's unchained,
everybody.
He's unmuzzled.
He's finally free.
He doesn't have to hide
behind his hand anymore.
Probably had to peel
that thing off this morning,
and then scrub off
the handprint
like a frat guy who woke up
with Sharpie on his face.
So, the scale
of the problems we're facing
cannot be overstated.
The U.S. set
yet another new record
for daily coronavirus deaths
on Trump's last day in office,
millions out of work,
facing homelessness,
child hunger
on the rise,
not to mention the structural
inequalities that existed
before Trump that got worse
during his presidency.
Trump left office yesterday
with 3 million fewer jobs
than when he started.
Meanwhile, Wall Street added
56 new billionaires
just since
the pandemic began.
Billionaires have added
a $1 trillion in wealth
since the start
of the pandemic,
including a group of just
10 billionaires alone
who added more than $400 billion
to their wealth.
That group includes
Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk,
Larry Page,
and Mark Zuckerberg --
who, despite the increase
in his wealth,
apparently still doesn't have
enough money to get a haircut
that doesn't make them
look like Data
playing a Roman emperor
on the holodeck.
"TNG" deep cut.
Personally, I can't wait for
incoming Senate budget chair,
and tonight's guest,
Bernie Sanders,
to dig in,
and get to work on that.
It's got to be
his life's dream
and the billionaire's
worst nightmare.
For one thing,
no one's better suited
to be in charge of a budget than
a guy who has one solid coat,
and that's it.
You know how,
when winter rolls around
and you look
in your closet,
and they are, like,
six different jackets
of varying sizes
and thickness.
That doesn't happen
to Bernie.
He has one coat that he wears
from October to February.
And if it's cold
any other time of the year,
he just does a lap
around the Capitol.
Then, there's the fact
that the vaccine rollout,
which we've had months
to prepare for,
and which could finally end
the pandemic,
has been a disaster.
In some cases,
vaccines are literally
getting thrown in the garbage,
which is just horrifying.
I mean, just give them away.
Give them to anyone.
Don't make me rifle through
the dumpster behind a CVS
looking for another vial
that says "Pfizer,"
because I will do it again.
At this point,
I'm gonna buy a knockoff vaccine
from one of the guys
selling bags in Times Square --
which will make sense,
as Pfizer
already looks like
a knockoff spelling.
Now, you might have expected
that, when Biden took office,
he would at least inherit
from Trump
a vaccine plan
that was bad,
or incomplete,
or both,
but it's even worse
than that.
It turns out there was actually
no plan at all.
-Brand-new reporting
about the vaccine rollout,
and it is much worse
than we thought.
Sources tell CNN that the Biden
administration is inheriting
a non-existent
vaccine distribution plan
from the Trump
administration.
-One source telling CNN, quote,
"There is nothing
for us to rework.
We are going to have to build
everything from scratch."
-This is criminal.
I mean, my God,
they knew this was coming,
and they did nothing.
Was the point of Warp Speed
to go as fast as possible
before crashing into
a brick wall?
The Trump administration
had a year,
and they didn't even sit down
and draw up a plan.
Was coronavirus task force
leader Mike Pence
in cold storage
during that whole time?
Did Dr. Birx get lost
in a pile of scarves?
Although, in a way,
I guess it's better
to just write your own plan
than have to rework
whatever the hell
Trump would have
come up with.
It's like fixing
a birthday cake
after putting your kid in charge
of making it.
I mean, you can add
as much sugar as you want,
but there's nothing you can do
about that ketchup icing.
So, Biden and Democrats
in the Senate have a series
of truly daunting challenges
in front of them.
Not to mention, they also have
to hold the previous president
and his allies accountable for
inciting a violent insurrection,
and investigate
what happened.
Just in the last
24 hours,
we've learned that the Army
lied about the involvement
of Michael Flynn's brother
in the military response
to the riot,
and a Republican congressman
has said the insurrection
was much worse
than the public realized.
All that information needs to
come out, and be investigated,
not to mention all the other
simultaneous crises
we've already mentioned.
By Biden's own admission,
the executive orders
are just a first step --
a first step that, predictably,
has Fox News losing its mind.
Joe Biden said yesterday,
"I want unity."
He talked about that
in his speech.
But the first thing he does,
the first order of business,
is to walk in,
sit down at the table,
and he has 17
executive orders
really wiping away much of
what President Trump did.
-They had all those
executive orders ready to go.
The immigration ones
particularly stuck out.
What did you think?
-Well, I was mystified.
In fact, my question is,
"What the heck is going on?"
-The weak, the frail,
the cognitively struggling Biden
signing this flurry
of executive orders.
-I'm sorry.
You think Biden is frail
and cognitively struggling?
The guy you supported
for the last four years
thought windmills
caused cancer,
read his own speeches
off a teleprompter
like he was trying to follow
the subtitles of foreign film,
and clutched the podium
the way a grandpa clutches
the steering wheel
when he drives through
midtown Manhattan.
Biden was literally jogging over
to reporters
at the inauguration yesterday
like a marathon runner
who comes in dead last
because he won't stop
taking selfies with the crowd.
Also, Karl Rove,
why are you still on TV?
And why are you still toting
around that stupid whiteboard?
If you're not gonna slink
away in shame and disgrace
the way you should,
at least get a new gig.
I mean, even Carrot Top
changed his hair for a while.
In fact, Republicans
are already plotting
to do everything possible
to stall the Democrats' agenda,
which includes a proposed
$1.9 trillion
stimulus and
healthcare package
and a raft of desperately
needed voting reforms.
Mitch McConnell
and other Republicans
are demanding that new
Senate majority leader,
Chuck Schumer, commit to keeping
the filibuster,
which is insane because, even if
Democrats don't get rid of it --
which they
absolutely should --
just the threat of getting rid
of it can be very powerful.
If you walk around Prospect Park
with a katana,
you don't actually
need to use it.
People are gonna, you know,
stay out of your way.
And now, even moderate Democrats
are pissed at McConnell
and the GOP for making
such a ridiculous demand.
Montana Senator Jon Tester
told Politico,
"Chuck Schumer
is the majority leader,
and he should be treated
like the majority leader.
We can get [bleep] done
around here,
and we ought to be focused
on getting stuff done."
First of all, it's awesome
when someone says [bleep]
for "stuff" the first time,
and then just switches
back to "stuff."
I am very down from more cursing
from Senate Democrats.
They might as well
take a cue from Tester,
and call their first bill
"The Get [Bleep] Done Act
of 20[bleep]21."
Second, he's right.
You guys lost.
Some of you even tried
to overthrow democracy.
You don't get
to make demands,
and you don't get forgiven
just because it didn't work.
When I tried to flip over
the table at Thanksgiving
because no one complimented
my cajun green beans,
only to realize the table
was way too heavy,
I didn't get to sit back down,
and pretend nothing happened.
I had to go outside,
and to quote my wife.
"think about the example
I'm setting for our kids."
President Biden
and Democrats in Congress
have a towering challenge
ahead of them.
They have to fix both
what Trump broke
and what was broken
before them,
all while holding him
and his enablers accountable,
as well as fixing
the conditions that created him.
It's a tall order,
especially since they're dealing
with a Republican Party
and right-wing media
that's run by...
-The weak, the frail,
the cognitively struggling.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses.
They need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can get the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.